[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire assistons depuis le début de
la crise du coc vide à une guerre des
âges comme le dit le courrier
international ton sacrifier les jeunes
pour sauver les vieux en les confinant
chez eux alors qu'il ne risquait pas
grand chose en leur interdisant depuis
de reprendre une vie normale en les
stigmatisant permanence et en les
obligeant à rembourser plus tard les
milliards que l'on emprunte aujourd'hui
et qu'une leur profiteront guère mais
plus âgés sont parfois le sentiment
inverse que c'est eux que l'on commence
à oublier que c'est eux que l'on
considère comme une charge comme un
problème comme une maladie que c'est eux
que l'on veut isoler tenir à distance un
visibiliser à lorp en débattre nous
avons invité andré comte sponville qui
est philosophe
vous venez publier un dictionnaire
amoureux de montaigne où l'on revisite
un philosophe qui a beaucoup à dire sur
notre époque qui y compris sur le co
vite 19 puisqu'il a connu la peste il
était médecin et maire de bordeaux à ce
moment là quand avoue andré comte
sponville à 68 ans vous semblez beaucoup
plus préoccupés par le sort de la
jeunesse que la moyenne des gens
sacrifier les jeunes à la santé des
vieux c'est une aberration avez vous dit
ça me donne envie de pleurer à ce point
là oui parce que je suis père de famille
c'est vrai j'ai 68 ans fait partie des
groupes à risque mais j'ai trouvé un
mois j'étais j'ai respecté le
confinement et je n'ai jamais condamné
mais je me suis étonnée et inquiétée que
personne ne parle du sort des jeunes
parce que d'évidence la crise économique
nous sommes maintenant allait peser
essentiellement sur eux la dette va
peser sur eux et quand je vois que
maintenant en plus on leur reproche de
sortir devant leurs copains ou de faire
la fête je trouve la situation
proprement scandaleuse qu'on soigne les
personnes âgées comprennent des malades
en général et les personnes âgées fasse
dix ans du co vide en particulier bien
sûr mais il faut aussi se soucier des
jeunes et encore une fois le père de
famille que je suis se fait plus de
souci pour l'avenir de ses enfants que
pour ma santé de presque septuagénaire
michel billé vous êtes sociologue
spécialisé dans les questions de
vieillesse et de handicap vous êtes le
président de l'union nationale des
instances les offices de retraités
personnes
ag j'ai également membre du comité
scientifique de l'observatoire de
l'âgisme
vous êtes l'auteur ou le coauteur de
plusieurs livres sur le vieillissement
que ce soit dictionnaire impertinent de
la vieillesse ou bien dépendance quand
tu nous tiens les daudet aux éditions
erès vous pensez qu'on a sacrifié les
jeunes à la santé des vieux
personnellement je ne le pense pas
évidemment si c'était vrai je serai très
vite d'accord avec andré comte sponville
pour dire à quel point ce serait
effrayant
scandaleux il n'est pas acceptable
d'imaginer de sacrifier les jeunes à la
santé des vieux si c'était en question
moi qui suis septuagénaire moi j'en ai
73 déjà et bien si c'était vrai
évidemment c'est ma vie à moi qu'il
faudrait sacrifier pour sauver celle des
jeunes linverse n'aurait aucun sens mais
j'aimerais bien faire l'hypothèse que
nous ne puisse que nous puissions ne
sacrifier ni la santé des jeunes ni la
santé des lieux on en reparle dans un
instant emmanuel les s vous avez 25 ans
vous présidez un groupe de réflexion et
de prospective baptisé génération 2030
et vous êtes l'auteur avec deux de vos
camarades d' hec et de sciences po d'une
tribune dans le monde intitulée la
génération confinement paiera pour les
boomers
j'avais l'impression que la jeune
génération est le dindon de la farce
je reçois je rejoins c'est largement ce
qu'elle dit andré comte sponville le
sentiment qu'on a eu et qui a été la
jeunesse de l'écriture de cette tribune
c'est que les jeunes été culpabilisés me
souviens de cette une du parisien qui
titrait le péril jeune sous-entendu les
jeunes qui se rassemblent en terrasse
après avoir passé trois 3 mois chez eux
trois mois confiné sans pouvoir sortir
son responsable aujourd'hui d'avoir un
peu d espace de liberté donc on voulait
apporter une voix qui rééquilibre le
débat qui de mieux que les jeunes pour
le faire personne ne pouvait le faire à
notre place en tout cas cela n'avait pas
été fait et donc l'idée c'est de dire
qu'il n'ya pas de culpabilisation des
jeunes qui soit acceptable dans ce
contexte d'autant que nous allons payer
un lourd tribut qui soit sur le plan de
la formation qui soit sur le plan
économique on a parlé de la dette et
donc les jeunes sont en réalité les
premières
économique mais non pas physique du coc
vide et ça il fallait le dire
mélissa petit docteur en sociologie vous
travaillez vous aussi sur le
vieillissement êtes l'auteur de
retraités cette richesse pour la france
chez l'harmattan et vous dirigez mixing
génération c'est un bureau d'études et
de conseil sur les questions de
longévité des seniors mais aussi sur ce
que l'on appelle maintenant la silver
economy
vous pensez que les jeunes vont payer
pour les vieux je ne suis pas tout à
fait d'accord je pense que la question
de l'opposition permanente qui revient
généralement dans le débat médiatique où
on oppose jeunes et vieux n'est
peut-être pas forcément la réponse est
que on peut y avoir un peu plus de
nuances dans tout ça et qu'un élément
qu'on oublie surtout c'est que c'est
notre expérience du vieillissement et
qu'un jour nous aussi on sera vieux et
qu'on ait beaucoup dans des débats
d'instants et pas forcément de demain
alors c'est vrai qu'on oppose et
beaucoup les les générations depuis le
début de la crise vu que vider et pour
cause on a remarqué très tôt qu
évidemment c'était plutôt quand on était
vieux quand qu'on aurait dû que vides
mais c'est vrai à peu près de toutes les
maladies on en meurt plus quand on est
vieux que quand on est jeune on en meurt
plus quand on est pauvre que quand on
est riche et on en meurt plus quand on
est un homme que quand on est une femme
c'est vrai toutes les balles a dit c'est
particulièrement vrai du que 8,19
puisqu'on sait à peu près maintenant les
les taux de létalité est qu un homme de
plus de 80 ans qui est qui est affecté
par le vide à peu près disons 15 % de
chances d'en mourir une femme de plus de
80 ans et entre 4,6 pour cent et 6 4%
et puis ça dépend quand on est des
quinquagénaires ça peut descendre à
moins de 1 % de risque d'en mourir
et puis quand on est moins quand on a
moins de 50 ans ça descend à moins de un
pour mille
cette évidence
important fait que j'ai un père de 92
ans et un fils de 20 ans mon père de 92
ans et mon fils de 20 ans ont été
confinés de la même manière pendant
trois 3 mois on n'a absolument pas fait
de différence c'était ça déjà un qui
vous avait alarmé andré comte sponville
puisque vous avez réagi très vite
c'était pendant le convive ou le
confinement que vous avez donné cette
interview qui parfois on a choqué
certains d'ailleurs oui
intel veut je n'ai pas sollicité un mais
on l'interrogé j'ai dit ce que je
pensais
et est ce que je pensais c'était déjà
que lakovic 19 à l'époque on ne parlait
au masculin et n'est quand même pas si
grave que certains journalistes
semblaient le diamant tout le monde
parlait de panique de peur au ventre de
tragédie de cauchemar et très vite on a
su que le taux de mortalité pour les
gens contaminés par la coved 19 étaient
inférieurs à 1% et maintenant nous d
aller d expertise qui vient entre 0,3 et
0,5 pour cent ça veut dire que c'est pas
une hécatombe qui s'annonçait un
quelqu'un qui attrapent la codi villa en
moyenne 99 5 % de chance d'en réchapper
s'il n'y a qu'un pas de quoi s'affoler
montagne que vous évoquez qui n'a jamais
été médecin qui était bien maire de
bordeaux qui n'a jamais été médecin mais
lui l'a connu la peste le taux de
létalité de l'appel du temps de
montaigne c'était proche de 200 % c'est
quand même autre chose que la coved 19
et ce qui m'a en effet un peu choqué
c'est qu'on mette cette pression sur les
jeunes qu'on les mette dans une
situation économique catastrophique d'or
d'une situation scolaire maintenant ce
qu'il faut en dire un mot aussi le
masque
je le porte mais j'étais prof pendant 24
ans quand j'imagine faire court masqués
devant trente gamins de seconde ou de
première eux-mêmes masqué mais vous
imaginez la déperdition d'attention de
communication des changes sans parler
des problèmes de déficit de discipline
vous imaginez apprendre une langue
étrangère avec un professeur masqué il
me semble qu'on est en train de 2,2
sacrifié l'éducation de nos enfants de
nos petits enfants pour protéger des
vieux on est deux ferait don des
protestants fait partie mais encore une
fois qu'ils ne risquent pas une
hécatombe
même quand on a plus de 80 ans le taux
de l'état
été et est encore intérieur à 10% ça
aurait été la peste vous pouvez
comprendre qu'on fasse tout pour se
protéger
moi je crois qu'il faut en effet
apprendre à vivre avec ce virus il faut
arrêter de paniquer il faut bien sûr se
protéger pour respecter les gestes
barrière ça va de soi il faut que les
vieux spécialement se protège mais
imaginez que le virus soit là pendant 20
ans pendant 30 ans vous imaginez vos
enfants vit pendant vingt ans entre par
deux visages dans la rue et de se
promener dans une ville sans visage sans
sourire avec le team hm de peur mais
c'est absolument insupportable pour une
maladie encore une fois acquis et dénis
n'y dans 80 % des cas et qu'il n'est
mort tels que dans nettement moins de 1%
des cas voilà il faut il faut
relativiser les choses d'être avec ta
lecture de montaigne qui a connu la
peste et qui ne s'en est pas pelé il a
fui la paix est bien sûr qui s'est
protégée aujourd'hui montaigne porterait
évidemment le masque dans le métro mais
il n'en faisait pas si j'ose dire tout
une maladie et quand je vois cette
espèce de film d'horreur qu'on nous fait
autour de la côte belge envie de dire
aux gens lisent et montagnes chiliennes
phrase de montagne à deux frappes de
montaigne que j'ai beaucoup cité lui
permet de rappeler si la première c'est
tu ne meurs pas de ce que tu es malade
humeur de ce que tu es vivant on dit la
mort fait partie de la vie on n'est pas
plus mortelle aujourd'hui qu'on l'était
il ya 50 ans et la deuxième phrase qui
m'importe encore plus montaigne écrit
joliment ce que ce dont j'ai le plus
peur c'est la peur eh bien c'est
exactement le sentiment que je ressens
aujourd'hui ce dont j'ai le plus peur
c'est cette peur qui est en train
d'envahir d'autres sociétés et qui en
effet étant à culpabiliser des jeunes
qui sont pourtant déjà victime de la
situation qu'on leur impose michel billé
vous disiez vous n'étiez pas d'accord
avec andré comte sponville alors
pourquoi alors pas d'accord je suis
souvent d'accord à travers tout ce qu'il
vient de dire souvent d'accord avec lui
j'ajouterai plus précisément deux ou
trois choses c'est que de la même
manière que les réactions vis-à-vis des
jeunes sont démesurés absurde dans un
certain nombre de situations elles sont
démesurés et absurde
vis-à-vis des plus vieux accueilli en
ehpad par exemple vieux que l'on va
auquel on va interdire des visites
coupés de leurs familles etc qui vont
mourir dans un isolement et j'oserais
dire dans un enfermement scandaleux
d'accord donc les abus que l'on peut
noter dans les prescriptions les
injonctions que l'on a fait sur la
manière de traiter la pandémie vis-à-vis
des jeunes
ces abus existent aussi ils sont mises
en scène différemment évidemment mais
ils ne sont pas de nature très
différente vis-à-vis des vieux c'est
pour ça que j'aimerais que l'on essaie
de ne pas opposer
jeunes et vieux mais qu'à chaque fois on
essaie de se poser la question comment
pourrait-on inventé une réponse
pertinente qui au-delà d'un confinement
peut-être nécessaire est encore en tout
cas qui ne transformerait pas ce
confinement en isolement et qui ne
transformerait pas cet isolement en
enfermement ce qui est malheureusement
le cas pour les plus âgés de nos
concitoyens très souvent en vacances
pour ville voulait ajouter quelque chose
pour dire que je suis absolument
d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être dit ma
belle mère est morte dans un ehpad
pendant le confinement n'ont pas dû
qu'au vide semble-t-il
elle n'avait pas vu ses enfants depuis
cinq semaines elle est morte seule c'est
une horreur alors là encore ça ne
condamne pas forcément le confinement
dessus pas expert c'est pas moins de
trancher là dessus mais je m'étonne
qu'on en ait si peu parlé que ça a été
une évidence pour tout le monde il faut
confiné il faut fermer les ehpad comme
si une femme qui meurt seul ce n'est pas
un problème au moins aussi grave que le
risque pour ces enfants éventuellement
de lui transmettre une maladie mortelle
dans 0.5 % des cas il s'agit en effet
pas t'es pas tout la lutte des agités
par plaques est le modèle elle est une
des classes sur la ville d âge il n'y a
pas du tout de de contradictions de ce
point de vue il faut à la fois s'occuper
des vieux et vous avez raison monsieur
de rappeler que les ehpad très souvent
sont des lieux de
privation de liberté le responsable qui
s'occupe des lieux du pression du
liberty ya quelques années avait demandé
à pouvoir se saisir des ehpad
il a raison alors ça ne retire rien au
formidable travail que font des gens qui
travaillent dans les ehpad qui font un
métier très difficile et tuent souvent
le font très bien
mais rappelons que beaucoup de gens qui
sont dans les ehpad ils sont contre leur
volonté
et si en plus on interdit à leurs
proches de venir les voir il ya une
amputation de liberté qui devient quand
même tout à fait inquiétant de voiliers
et donc de ce point de vue le
confinement et essais pour protéger la
santé des plus vieux mais il a nuit
aussi à beaucoup de ces vieillards si
vous voulez et donc il faut qu'on
apprenne qu'on réfléchisse à tout ça on
va pas tranché le débat ce soir mais je
crois que dans la proche du confinement
1 on n'a pas osé
assez parlé d'économie j'étais je crois
le premier à dire attention le
couinement ça va coûter atrocement cher
ce sont les jeunes qui vont en payer le
coût on objecter que je voulais protéger
le grand capital plutôt que la santé des
vieux alors à ce niveau de polémiques
évidemment le débat devient difficile
chacun sait que la crise c'est pas le
grand capital qui en souffrent le plus
c'est évidemment les plus pauvres en
l'occurrence les jeunes et puis j'ai dit
aussi attention de risque de ne pas
amputer nos libertés vous appelle
l'ordre sanitaires aux fouilles à une
tentation chez certains qui consiste à
dire la santé c'est le plus important et
donc la liberté ça vient après si on
peut aussi on réduit liberté c'est pas
grave non moi je tiens à la santé mais
je tiens aussi un ami liberté il faut
arriver à tenir bon sur les deux et pas
se précipiter dans cette évidence que
dès que la maladie est là tout s'arrête
et seule la santé compte on reviendra
sur les conséquences économiques pour la
jeune génération
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission emmanuel beth sur la situation
qui a été fait aux à votre génération et
et aux plus jeunes
depuis le début de la crise du comics je
le disais vous avez été confinés
exactement comme les plus âgés qui eut
le risque est bien plus en contactant la
maladie que vous et depuis
il a sorti depuis le déconfinement on
sait bien que ce sont les jeunes
caustique bêtise en permanence ça a
commencé quasiment le premier jour ils
sont vu la mauvaise idée de se
rassembler au bord du canal saint-martin
et plus de cafés ouverts y avait plus
rien on leur envoyer la police quand
même
comment l'avez vous vécue vous en
général alors je voudrais d'abord lever
un malentendu il s'agit pas d'opposer
les générations se serait ce serait
vraiment déplacé de notre part au
contraire il s'agit de rééquilibrer le
débat en disant que nous sommes attachés
à la solidarité intergénérationnelle
dans la mesure où en france la
solidarité internationale n'est pas
simplement une question économique c'est
aussi une question fondamentale dans
notre socle républicain c'est ce qui
permet aux jeunes et aux plus âgés de
tenir ensemble au sein d'une même nation
donc il s'agit simplement d'équilibrer
le débat et non pas d'opposer donc
sortons peut-être de ce manichéisme ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas notre volonté
ensuite sur le confinement les les
jeunes se sont confinés mais parce qu'il
le pensait effectivement qu'il fallait
protéger les usagers
ils l'ont fait avec volonté et il ya une
part de fierté dans cette génération de
se dire que nous nous sommes confinés
nous avons sacrifié une partie de notre
liberté pour protéger les plus âgés donc
il n'y a pas de sujet à ce niveau là ce
qui ce qui a alerté notre ce qui nous a
indignés c'est le discours qui a suivi
le confinement c'était le déconfinement
un jeune a besoin d espace
un enfant a besoin d'espacé il a besoin
d'un peu de liberté alors c'est vrai
éviter des comportements qui était
déplacé dans le sens où vraiment il y
avait beaucoup de jeunes qui parfois été
assemblés qui ne respectaient pas les
gestes barrière mais c'était minoritaire
dans l'extrême majorité des cas les
jeunes ont respecté les gestes barrières
ont respecté les distances lorsqu'ils se
sont rassemblés c'est à l'air libre à
l'air libre là on sait qu'à l'air libre
le virus virus here que moi voilà donc
il faut pas généraliser
simplement il faut avoir un regard avoir
un regard nuancé et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que votre émission
s'appelle interdit d'interdire
c'est un slogan de mai 68 la génération
de mes parents c'est la génération de 68
qui revendiquait l'interdiction
d'interdire qui revendiquait la police
la possibilité de jouir sans entraves
alors c'est cette jeunesse là n'est pas
une jeunesse qui ce wiki jouir sans
entraves c'est pas une jeunesse qui
demande qu'on interdise interdit
d'interdire
c'est une jeunesse qui simplement
demandent à se réunir de temps en temps
en respectant les distances à l'air
libre
il me semble qu'il ya rien de bien
méchant là-dedans et le discours facile
de culpabilisation des jeunes revient
assez régulièrement
mais il fait fi de la réalité et
j'ajouterai un dernier point c'est que
la rentrée scolaire a permis de voir que
les amphithéâtres était bondé et que les
souvent lorsque les élèves ne respectez
pas les gestes barrière c'était contre
leur gré parce qu'ils se retrouvent dans
les escaliers
pendant pendant le court parce qu'ils se
retrouvent dans un espace surchargé qui
ne sont pas ventilé parce que les
amphithéâtres ont été construits dans
les années 60
donc lorsqu'il ne respectent pas les
gestes barrière c'est contre leur gré
donc il faut voilà avoir un regard
nuancé les jeunes sont responsables
discours d' irresponsabilité des jeunes
me semble dépassée et un peu caricatural
de même on a pu constater il ya eu un
certain nombre de manifestations contre
le port du masque en allemagne d'abord
puis dans d'autres pays y compris en
france
c'était plutôt des gens âgés qui
manifestaient c'était pratiquement
jamais des jeunes mélissa petit oui en
effet je pense que on voit bien que la
question des libertés de la sécurité ou
la prise de risque c'est quelque chose
qui transcende les âges c'est à dire
qu'on le voit utiliser
andré comte sponville sur les jeunes la
formation ou même emmanuelle et bien on
le revoit aussi sur la question du
télétravail ou du travail en présentiel
avec ce port du masque et même avec ce
qui se passe dans les ehpad même à
domicile
donc est ce qu'on a envie c'est dans
quelle société veut pour preuve il dans
une société qui accepte de prendre des
risques dans une société qui va il est
pro sécuritaire et donc se positionner
en enlevant des libertés c'est un vrai
débat de société et jude j'aimerais
revenir sur quelques points pour moi n'a
pas forcément protéger les yeux on a
cherché à protéger dalli parce qu'on
avait probablement peur d'une mort et
qu'on a peur de mourir et on a peur
aussi de vieillir donc la question
c'était esponde à poser aux plus âgés
classement ehpad ou à domicile
la question de comment vous les tulipes
7 ce confinement comment va-t-il vivre
là le poste confinement c'est aussi des
sujets promet un peu de côté aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'associations de retraités
s'arrête parce que les mesures sont trop
strictes pour pouvoir envisager des
dispensation des port du masque et
cetera donc comment on arrive à recréer
si des possibilités aux mêmes
que pour emmanuel et pour les jeunes qui
ont envie de circuler et bien les vieux
aussi ont envie de garder leur mobilité
et est dans l'espace public parce qu ils
le sont de toute façon peu et de plus
enfin un visibiliser et j'en ai vu deux
derniers éléments on parle des vieux et
des jeunes comme des catégories
homogènes
or on voit bien que des différences à la
fois de classe sociale de genre de
rapport à nos vulnérabilités et au
rapport au territoire et serra qui font
que ces catégories sont hétérogènes
est-ce que poser aussi juste emmanuel à
la fin c'est ce cet élément de
solidarité en effet nos politiques
publiques depuis 1945 ont été basées sur
de la solidarité entre les générations
où entre les classes sociales
est ce qu'il faut ou pas repenser des
modèles
c'est aussi dire est une discussion à
avoir dans cette question de la société
dans laquelle on veut vivre aujourd'hui
sécurité liberté ou pièces de vie toute
façon comment vivre dans un système
nouveau mutualisent les risques
au fond c'est toujours ce qui risque le
moins qui payent pour ceux qui risquent
le plus andré comte sponville ce qui
risque le moins d'avoir un cancer du
poumon parce qu'il ne fume pas paye pour
ceux qui fument et risque le plus
d'avoir un cancer du poumon
c'est le règle c'est la base même de la
sécurité sociale oui c'est l'idée de
solidarité qui n'est pas toujours
moralement aussi satisfaisante qu'on le
voudrait pour les raisons que vous
évoquez mais qui vaut mieux que le
chacun pour soi
1 je ne pense pas que vous souhaitiez
que on laisse les fumeurs mourir sans
soins ni qu'on les laisse payer seul le
coût de leur traitement bien c'est la
fin de la solidarité et donc au fond
c'est la fin de la vie sociale telle que
nous la connaissons est telle que nous
la voulons tank où est la solidarité est
une chose évidemment très importantes y
compris la solidarité inter
générationnelle
mais attention s'agissant de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle qui
mesure très importante qu'on la voit
donc dans système des retraites les
actifs payent pour les pour les
retraités très bien mais on oublie
toujours de dire que traditionnellement
c'est solidarité intergénérationnelle
elle est orientée elle est asymétrique
c'est-à-dire qu'au fond les parents se
sacrifie pour leurs enfants
bien plus évidemment que les enfants ne
sacrifie pour leurs parents et c'est
très bien n'importe quelle paire
n'importe quelle mère n'importe quel
grand père aux grands-mères donnerait sa
vie sans hésiter pour ses enfants ou ses
petits enfants
lequel d'entre nous accepterait que ses
enfants ou ses petits-enfants
compromettent leur vie pour la nôtre
mais personne bien sûr ce serait
totalement inacceptable voiliers et dont
je crois qu'il faut garder aussi ce je
dirais cet enracinement anthropologique
il est normal que les parents se
dévouent pour leurs enfants plus que les
enfants pour leur temps ça veut pas dire
que les enfants ne s'occupent pas de
leurs parents quand ils seront vieux et
on sait tous que en gros on le fait
voiliers mais ce qui m'a choqué dans la
période actuelle mais déjà depuis
quelques années c'est comme le système
de santé vous l'avez dit c'est les vieux
qui sont malades c'est pas de leur faute
d'essayer comme ça m'est donc c'est les
vieux qui coûte cher et comme on finance
avec la dette c'est les jeunes qui
payent il ya quand même un problème une
espèce d'inversion justement de cette
solidarité intergénérationnelle
traditionnellement orientés des plus
vieux au service des plus jeunes qui
n'entrent inde a versé pour des raisons
économiques des plus jeunes au service
des plus vieux alors on va pas encore
une fois reproché aux vieux j'en fais
partie des le plus malade que les jeunes
il faut bien sûr sauver notre système de
santé vous bien sûr défendre la sécurité
sociale qui est l'un des plus
formidables progrès de toute l'histoire
de l'humanité mais faut pas en rajouter
perpétuellement dans l'accablement déjà
n'est sûr pas surtout pas dans leur
culpabilisation et puis faut aussi
s'interroger sur un certain discours
médical j'ai vu un appel de plusieurs
médecins pas le conseil scientifique
mais qui en gros 10 heures puis 10 est
littéralement il faut siffler la fin de
la récréation
mais c'est quoi ce discours qu'est ce
que c'est que cette infantilisation pour
qu'ils nous prend-il pour qui se
prend-il
nous ne sommes pas des enfants ne sommes
pas leurs élèves ce ne sont pas nos
professeurs de quel droit prétendent-ils
siffler la fin de la récréation
nous sommes des citoyens et les médecins
sont citoyens au même titre que les
autres et pas plus tard qu on demande
l'avis des experts des scientifiques il
va de soi qu'ils ont une information à
donner mais ce ne sont pas les experts
qui gouverne c'est le peuple français
par la médiation
de ses représentantes est ce que j'ai
appelé le pan médicalisé dartout délégué
à la médecine c'est un danger pour notre
démocratie
parce que d'ailleurs on l'a vu je vais
vous dire au moment du confinement
moi j'étais un peu réservé gène est allé
poser des problèmes énormes et j'ai
voulu ferme comme conseiller raymond
aron je me suis demandé qu'est ce que je
ferais à la place de macron bien je vais
vous dire ce qui m'a le plus effrayer
ses je me suis dis honnêtement j'aurais
fait la même chose
pas du tout parce que je pensais que le
confinement c'était la meilleure
solution
en vérité je n'en savais rien et encore
aujourd'hui je n'en sais trop rien mais
parce qu'il y avait une telle pression
médiatique médical avec quinze médecins
qui parlaient tous les soirs à la télé
au journal du 20h du 20h et puis une
telle peur dans la population que
finalement nos gouvernants n'avait plus
aucune marge de manoeuvre la pression
médical médiatique était telle qu'il
n'avait plus le choix et ça c'est
dangereux pour la démocratie
parce qu'au fond on encore c'est pas les
médecins qui gouverne c'est pas les
experts qui gouverne c'est surtout pas
la peur qui doit gouverner et je crois
qu'il faut redonner à la politique en
général c'est à dire à nous tous en tant
que citoyens d'abord mais aussi à nos
élus redonner à la politique sa part
d'autonomie et j'ai crié casse cou quand
j'ai eu le sentiment que ce pan
médicales istm envahissant était en
train de réduire l'autonomie du
politique
on fait une pause en reprend ce bébé
juste après
[Musique]
il a été baptisé tout simplement france
relance d'une ambition et d'une ampleur
historique pour arrêter les les
croyances quasi religieuse sur le fait
que l'état donne une impulsion à
l'économie ça n'est jamais arrivé
quand on fait encore une fois un plan de
relance généraliste il ya assez peu près
si vous ne satisfait personne
sur les 40 milliards attendus de
l'europe on leur en donne sens et on en
récupère 40 donc sans moins 40 ça veut
dire qu'on est en l'air de 60 là où il
fallait mettre le paquet c'est beaucoup
plus sur les petites entreprises versus
très grosse et donc vous ne fait que
creuser encore les inégalités qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans nos pays
là il annonçant 60 mille emplois créés
mais on va en détruire combien
[Musique]
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs a
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
et finalement tu mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois voyez des images assez
touchants de l'armée qui était presque
impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques ils
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus sais pas s'ils savent que c'est
leur fin ils se préparent le seul
langage qu'ils connaissaient la violence
il ne va pas trop violent mais on va
rester
[Musique]
reprend ce débat avec le philosophe
andré comte-sponville avec michel billé
qui est sociologue et président de
l'union nationale des instances et
office de retraités et personnes âgées
avec emmanuel bezzaz qui est présidente
de génération 2030 et mélissa petit qui
est présidente de mixing generation
alors qu'on vient d'entendre andré comte
sponville évoqué cette phrase qui
effectivement m'avait frappé aussi il
est temps de siffler la fin de la
récréation
on voyait bien à ce moment-là que
c'était à la fois les médecins qui ceux
qui se protègent et qui dit attendez on
veut pas revivre ce qu'on a vécu au mois
de mars
mais c'était aussi une manière de parler
à la jeunesse et de lui dire vous ne
pouvez pas reprendre une vie normale
vous n'en avez pas le droit vous risquer
de mettre en danger des gens plus
fragile que vous donc grosso modo
rentrez chez vous mettez un masque tenez
vos distances et ne croyez pas que vous
allez pouvoir reprendre comme ça une vie
normale on a même vu fleurir de plus en
plus ce slogan pas toujours très connu
mais amusant au livre met référence
évidemment à black lips matters mais
comme si tout à coup on était on avait
oublié que les vider des gens âgés qu'on
tait et on se voit on entend bien
parfois chez les les plus fragiles comme
on les appelle donc les plus âgés une
méfiance à l'égard de la jeune
génération qui ne respecteraient pas ces
fameux gestes-barrières michel billé aux
glyphes batteur s'est justifié aveu à
vos yeux
certainement et à cela moi j'ai envie de
répondre en utilisant un autre slogan un
autres anglicismes ou pseudo anglicismes
puisqu'il a été un petit peu détournée
hold up
l'expression n'est pas de moi c'est
marie françoise fuchs qui l'a largement
valorisés debout les vieux deux bouts
les vieux ne nous taisons pas le pire
serait que on ferme la gueule des jeunes
parce qu'ils sont jeunes et qu'on ferme
la gueule des vieux parce qu'ils sont
vieux et là on aura tous perdu
là où chacun croit essayé
gagner quelque chose deux bouts les
vieux le moment est venu de parler de
dire d'où nous venons comment voulez
vous qu'on ne reproche pas à des jeunes
adolescents de croire que la vie
commence avec eux si nous les vieux nous
ne leur avons jamais raconter d'où nous
venons il faut donc absolument que ces
générations qui se succèdent se parlent
s'écoutent se rencontrent se transmettre
sans cela évidemment nous allons à une
catastrophe de guerre des générations de
sacrifice des uns et des autres qui est
d'ailleurs un hic motif assez assez
effrayant est récurrent depuis très
longtemps on se demande si la génération
qui est qu'il y avait 20 en 1914
évidemment elle a été la génération
sacrifiée mais celles qui avaient 20 ans
elle a été la génération sacrifiée celle
qui a fait la guerre d'algérie
génération sacrifiée
en 1999 il ya un rappeur français qui
s'appelle rohff qui a exactement qui
donne ce titre à une de ses chansons un
de ses textes que franchement moi je
n'apprécie pas spécialement
n'empêche que me voilà donc il y a tout
le temps pour une génération la
possibilité la question que tout de se
dire et si nous étions la génération
sacrifiée
mais si les jeunes si la génération qui
a 20 ans regarde ceux qui en ont 70 en
se disant eux c'est boomer ils ont eu
tout et nous nous n'avons rien nous
n'aurons rien évidemment ils se trompent
non les vieux n'ont pas tous eu les
générations de 68 il a fallu qu'elle
emmène des combats des luttes pour
obtenir des choses et bien le monde
s'ouvre devant cette génération qui a 20
ans ce monde je les fais pour toi disait
le père rose c'est une maladie déjà 10 l
enfant ou souvenez de maxime le
forestier
oui mais voilà oui il y à un chantier
gigantesque à ouvrir ouvrons le ensemble
pour que les vieux et les jeunes
bâtissent ensemble cette société qu'il
nous faut réinventer
pour l'instant le chantier ce sont les
milliards du plan de relance les
milliards qui ont été injectés dans
l'économie française pour la soutenir
ces milliards on les a empruntées
emmanuel blaise était le sujet de votre
tribune
vous disiez à la fois que ces milliards
il va falloir les rembourser un jour et
ce sera votre génération la jeune
génération la génération sacrifiée
ducobu de 19 qui devra les rembourser
mais en plus ces milliards ne lui
profiteront même pas bah oui en fait ce
que nous disons c'est que la dette en
soit d'un point de vue économique n'est
pas mauvaise par nature il ya une dette
qui peut être utile à l'économie c'est
la dette qu'on contracte en période de
crise comme on l'a fait pendant le co
lead comme on l'a fait en 2009 pour
relancer l'économie c'est la dette de
relance et une deuxième titre de dette
qui peut être utile c'est la dette
d'investissement
c'est celle qui permet de préparer la
croissance future et nous on a analysé
en fait la dette des 40 dernières années
on a aussi regardé la dette qu vide mais
surtout la dette des 40 dernières années
et on s'aperçoit qu'en fait la dette qui
était un niveau de 100 % au moment où on
est entré dans la crise était surtout
une dette structurelle c'était pas une
dette qui a été contracté pour investir
ou pour pallier des crises économiques
c'est une dette qui finalement a servi à
financer le train de vie de l'état
est ce qu'on dit c'est que cette dette
va il va falloir leur rembourser un jour
aujourd'hui on dit ce n'est pas un
problème parce que les taux d'intérêt
sont bas
sauf que les taux d'intérêt ils peuvent
être bas aujourd'hui ils peuvent être
aux deux mains ça s'est vu dans d'autres
pays et le jour où on aura besoin
d'avoir des marges de manoeuvre
budgétaires son appel des espaces
budgétaires pour investir massivement
dans la transition écologique
on sait qu'il faut par exemple 150
milliards d'euros en france pour la
transition écologique pour l'instant on
annonce et 30 milliards du plan de
relance c'est bien mais c'est pas assez
quand on aura besoin d'investir on aura
des boulets aux pieds parce que
justement on n'aura plus les marges de
manoeuvre budgétaires pour le faire
parce qu'on va entrer dans ce grand défi
dont vous parliez monsieur ce grand défi
ce grand défi pour l'avenir ce grand
défi écologique un défi de
reconstruction ils n'auront pas les
moyens les moyens pour agir donc c'est à
la fois un motif d'inquiétude est
également un motif qui nous pousse à
vouloir agir à vouloir nous engage
il ya dans la jeunesse aujourd'hui non
pas un désespoir mais une volonté de
s'engager résolument pour changer les
choses
mélissa petit oui c'est un peu c'est ce
mot d'ordre par rapport à sensibiliser
les derniers intervenants réussira à
s'engager ensemble qui ont des
opportunités en sortant de cette crise
pour pouvoir créer une autre société en
tous les cas une société un peu
différente plus en lien entre les âges
bien sûr avec les plus âgés et les plus
jeunes mais aussi sans oublier la
génération intermédiaire on me dit
parfois quand on parle de conflit entre
les générations lien entre les
générations on a aussi besoin de cette
génération intermédiaire on a aussi est
de toute façon on voit bien qu'on porte
des valeurs transversale on a tous des
prises de conscience sur le climat sur
les questions ni aux féministes sur les
questions liées au racisme sur elle a
besoin de s'unir et de créer des
perspectives communes
on a et de fait peut-être que le premier
élément c'est à voir un peu ce qu'ils
disent est d'une certaine manière michel
billé et que moi je vous répète un peu
suivent c'est comment on réinvestit nos
lignes et on réinvestit les liens à la
fois aux fins des descendants et des
ascendants en fonction de là où en est
sûr dans notre hub parcours de vie et
donc on a besoin les uns les autres et
si on réinvestit nos lignes on
comprendra mieux aussi le plus âgé
on comprendra mieux nos plus jeunes et
on pourra aussi réussir à s'investir
plus facilement dans des lieux de
rencontres ou dans des échanges de
proximité parce qu'on a besoin
aujourd'hui de proximité le confinement
ou là en tous les cas fait à apparaître
sur le rayon de distance sur lequel on
pouvait circuler et donc besoin de
réinvestir cette proximité avec des
liens entre les âges
et puis un besoin oui il ya besoin de
onlive meters mais toutes les ligues
compte mais il ya un besoin de deux buts
certes de prendre la parole
oui debout les vieux mais aussi sur
contre 7 invisibilisation
invisibilisation dans la circulation et
l'espace public
il n'y a pas que les individus qui
doivent faire des choses il y à aussi
par exemple besoin de trottoirs
peut-être plus important il y a besoin
de vous
ite et aussi d'assises qui ont été
longuement surpris mais de pouvoir
mettre des feux qu'ils puissent voir
combien de temps peut circuler pour
pouvoir être dans cet espace pour
pouvoir être vu et donc pour pouvoir
derrière ou à parler
alors je voudrais pas avoir l'air d'être
comme souvent les médias de vouloir
absolument opposé les les jeunes et les
vieux
néanmoins on voit bien depuis le début
du que vides que effectivement et de la
crise économique qui s'en sort une crise
que nous avons totalement provoqué en
arrêtant en mettant l'économie sur pause
pour confirmer la moitié de la
population du globe
on voit bien que ce sont les jeunes qui
en ont été les premières victimes je
passe dans un pays comme le nôtre bien
entendu ce sont eux qui ont perdu leur
travail
ce sont eux qui sont les moins
indemnisés pour les paroles tout ce
qu'ils ont perdu pendant cette crise ce
sont eux qu'on a confiné quand ils ne
pourraient quasiment aucun risque en
contractant la maladie ce sont eux qu'on
stigmatise pour leur comportement
aujourd'hui
et en plus c'est vrai nous empruntons de
l'argent qui va pas laure est tellement
redistribuées en tout cas c'est pas eux
qui en profiteront le plus c'est à ça
que vous pensiez à michel billé veut
intervenir sinon alesi me fait oublier
tout ça m'amène à dire attention quand
on emploie l'expression les jeunes
paieront pour les boomers
non les jeunes ne paieront pas pour les
boumeurs les jeunes perron bien sûr pour
la société française tout entière et
même pour la société européenne et au
delà toute entière
ce n'est pas tout ces décisions que vous
évoquez là c'est par les vieux qui les
ont demandé n'est ce pas ce ne sont pas
les boumeurs qui ont voulu que la
société s'arrête qu'on emprunte que
ceux-ci que cela non non non c'est pas
les boumeurs ils n'en sont pas
responsables ils en sont autant victime
que les plus jeunes
attention à cela autrement on va marcher
sur la tête à mon avis alors réponses de
2 des manuels blaise est ce parce que
c'est lui après tout qui a employé cette
expression et je vous donnerai la parole
après andré comte sponville non alors
quand on dit les boomers
on dise plutôt une époque mais pas
forcément des personnes en particulier
il n'y a pas de volonté d'opposer là
dessus simplement il faut distinguer le
débat ne se situe pas sur le même plan
pour les jeunes et les plus âgés mais
alors c'est vrai que ces catégories sont
un peu floues mais bon disons les jeunes
et les plus âgés
les jeunes sont les premières victimes
économiques les plus âgés sont les
premières victimes physiques alors c'est
très complexe et on l'a dit pour une
pour nos décideurs de concilier ces deux
intérêts qu'ils sont contradictoires
mais vous l'avez dit les premières
victimes économiques ce sont les plus
jeunes
gd beaucoup d'exemples d'amis qui ont
perdu qui ont perdu leur emploi pendant
pendant cette période il ya un jeune sur
six qui a perdu son emploi pendant
depuis le début de la crise pourquoi
parce que les entreprises elles font là
justement sur les contrats courent les
cdd or les contrats courent c'est
essentiellement des jeunes aux états
unis on n'a pas encore les chiffres pour
la france mais aux états unis
vous avez maintenant 52 % des jeunes qui
vivent chez leurs parents
les 18 29 ans et cinq points de plus
qu'au début de la crise il ya également
ceux qui rentrent sur le marché de
l'emploi et à 700 milles jeunes qui
rentrent sur le marché de l'emploi
sept cent mille jeunes c'est exactement
le chiffre d'emplois qui ont été
détruits depuis le début de la crise
nous avaient potentiellement 1,4 million
de chômeurs donc il s'agit pas de
d'opposer mais simplement situer le
débat qui est complexe évidemment parce
que les intérêts sont contradictoires et
c'est aussi la difficulté de cette crise
qui dépasse tout le monde mais les
victimes économiques sont
essentiellement les jeunes
lorsque vous êtes à la retraite nous
avaient pas votre niveau de vie
économique ne change pas il n'y a pas
d'évolution
lorsque vous êtes un jeune actif votre
niveau de vie évoluent si vous perdez
votre emploi voilà ce que nous disons
une femme retraité sur deux vivent
seules
aujourd'hui en france une femme retraité
sur deux est au seuil de pauvreté
vous vous rendez compte alors il ya
beaucoup à dire oui mais je veux dire
que ça c'était déjà le cas avant la
crise c'était déjà le cas et asus est un
autre problème c'est pas le fait de la
crise et ça je suis d'accord avec vous
mais c'était le cas avant la crise
grecque quand tu pars vivier à la crise
qu vide oui et moi je suis d'accord avec
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites
mais
je me méfie un peu des discours quand
même trop consensuelle d'abord une
observation
s'il ya une génération qui n'a pas été
sacrifiée c'est bien celle des baby
boomers
parce qu'on n'a pas connu la guerre
d'algérie on a connu mai 68 c'était pas
du malheur on a eu la pilule pour notre
sexualité et était en plus avant le sida
et maintenant on a le viagra pour
agrémenter notre vieillesse donc 6ème
génération qui est pas à plaindre c'est
la mienne et faut pas mettre de ce point
de vue tout les aérations sur le même
plan ce qui arrive à nos jeunes gens est
une catastrophe
je vois des reportages oui il l'a
rappelé sept cent mille jeunes qui ont
fini leurs études en juin ou en juillet
dernier et qui arrive sur un marché du
travail sinistrés mais effectivement ça
me donne envie de pleurer combien de
mois combien d'années de 2,2 chômage et
puis autre chose qu'il faut dire ces
mots et choqué en disant deux choses la
première c'est un n'oublions pas de
parler d'économie parce que la misère
tue aussi la fin qu davantage et plus
vite que la maladie et 2 j'ai dit
évidemment tous les êtres humains sont
égaux en droits et en dignité
quel que soit leur âge ça va de soi mais
toutes les morts ne se valent pas parce
qu'il est quand même plus triste de
mourir à 20 ou 30 ans que de mourir à 68
ans et mon âge ou à 81 ans et l'âge
moyen des décès de lakovic 19
parce qu'on présente aussi comme une
catastrophe le fait que les gens meurent
mais il ya un moment où il faut bien
malgré tous mourir il meurt de la coved
peut-être trois ans ou dix ans plus tôt
c'est très triste et sauvons tout ce
qu'on peut sauver bien surveillé mais on
peut peut mettre sur le même plan une
vie de 20 ou 30 ans dans sa difficulté
et puis une autre vie qui avons bien
vécu
on va être on espère qu'il va durer
encore plusieurs années voyez mais je
crois que c'est important doser le dire
et toutes les morts ne se valent pas il
est plus triste de mourir à 20 ou 30 ans
qu'à 68 ou ou quatre maintenant imaginer
que la copine 19 tue en moyenne les gens
à 95 ans ça serait quand même les choses
imaginez l inverse qu elle les tue en
moyenne à 30 ans comme la grippe
espagnole parce que la grippe espagnole
caf et 50 millions de morts en 1114 918
avait un pic de mortalité entre 30 et 40
ans c'est pas du tout la même chose
et donc cette copie de 19,1 elle est pas
si grave que ça le taux de létalité est
entre 0
3 et 0 25% je ne me lasserai pas de le
répéter mais deux elle a le bon goût de
tuer plutôt des gens qui en plus de 65
ans et pour la moitié d'entre eux qui en
plus de 85 ans et est donc on ne peut
quand même pas écraser nos jeunes gens
pour protéger la santé de nos
octogénaire ya un moment où il faut
arrêter
et puis thomas janvier de dire qu'on
arrête d'embêter nos jeunes gens moi je
dis à mes enfants profiter de la vie
protégez vous soyez prudentes et ne pas
n'importe quoi mais surtout ne renoncez
à aucun plaisir pour protéger ma santé
ma santé à moi je m'en charge si je veux
rester confinés chez moi me cloîtrée
dans mon appartement
j'en suis libre mais j'ai quand même pas
demander à mes enfants de renoncer à
sortir à danser à faire du sport sous
prétexte que leur papa est revenue un
peu fragile
je trouve ce discours-là profondément
choquant c'est pas celui qui était tenu
par nos deux intervenants mais si tu les
as entendu tenu par plusieurs personnes
à la télévision et donc voila moi je dis
priorité aux jeunes quand j'en parle du
maquereau en dire nous la priorité au
mode au début du confinement macro
disait la priorité des priorités c'est
de protéger les plus vulnérables
oui c'est vrai en temps de crise ça n'y
était réguler autrement dit en mars ou
en avril quand il y avait des centaines
de morts ou des 1000 morts chaque jour
maintenant il faut apprendre comme dit à
nouveau mercredi maintenant macron à
juste titre il faut apprendre à vivre
avec le virus
on ne va pas faire pendant 20 ou 30 ans
notre prière absolue de protéger les
plus vieux d'entre nous est bonne foi je
peux le dire parce que j'en fait partie
moi avec mai 68 ans en tant que père de
famille en tant que futur grand père
j'ai envie de dire sur le long terme la
priorité des priorités c'est les jeunes
en général et les enfants en particulier
en cause pour ville ce que vous voulez
dire que vous aviez dit
auparavant vous êtes quasiment le seul à
le dire à la télévision il faut quand
même faut quand même le savoir sont des
choses qu'on entend dans la ville un
gros on au sein de votre âge qui dit ça
mais à la télévision jamais jamais à la
télévision il faut dire parce que c'est
là que j'appelle le reste ce que
j'appelle le sanitairement correct comme
le politiquement correct il ya des
choses qu'on n'a pas le droit de dire
avec lesquels au fond tout nous d'accord
quand je dis qu'il est plus triste de
mourir à 30 ans 15 68 ans personne ne
dit le contraire oui mais c'est choquant
de le dire et des mesures crois que ce
sanitaire n'en correct est dangereux
parce qu'il risque de nous mener
justement un ordre sanitaire qui est
beaucoup plus grave parce que le talent
étirements correct c'est des choses n'a
pas le droit de dire l'ordre sanitaire
c'est des choses qu'on n'a pas le droit
de faire mais attention parce que là le
passage de l'un à l'autre
je peux devenir insidieux et peut-être
un jour irréversible et donc vous avez
raison je m'étonne d'être si seuls dans
ce combat là que je ne mène pas par
intérêt personnel mais que je mène je
dirais par conviction de père de famille
et pour moi c'est extrêmement important
je viens de faire un texte pour un livre
collectif écrit surtout par des médecins
de maladies infectieuses et je les
appelais brève réflexion d'un philosophe
père de famille parce que ma position en
l'occurrence sur le cog hill
elle est déterminée d'abord par le fait
que j'ai trois enfants qui sont de
jeunes adultes des trentenaires et je ne
veux surtout pas qu'il sacrifie en fois
que ce soit leur vie leur bonheur le
livre leur liberté alors à la santé de
leurs vieux papa mais licha petit globe
d'accord je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec andré comte sponville je dirais
peut-être un peu différemment ou
peut-être plus largement c'est à dire
que on est tous responsables
on nous aide tous infantilisés et on
oublie particulièrement que l'individu
citoyen et responsable et qu'en effet et
bien arrêtons profitons de la vie mais
alors pas que les jeunes gérer profitons
tous de la vie comme on l'entend tout en
étant responsable de soi parce que
peut-être peu andré comte sponville ou
des amis qu'il a de son âge a aussi eu
aussi envie de profiter mais que l'est
son exemple je me permets votre exemple
est particulièrement intéressant parce
qu'au final vous êtes un boomer et puis
vous allez sûrement payé pour vos
enfants
certains les plus jeunes ils sont
douchées par
cette crise économique vont avoir une
augmentation et des difficultés sur le
marché de l'emploi
il n'y a pas que les plus jeunes la
crise économique touche les entreprises
d'autres strates d'âge également jusqu'à
la fin de carrière un individu sur deux
passe par la case chômage avant
d'arriver à la retraite c'était un
statistique avant 2020 donc on voit bien
qu'on est quasiment tous touchés par
cette crise économique bien sûr on peut
dire les plus jeunes ça peut être plus
complexe
moi j'ai un peu d'espoir sur la question
des jeunes générations parce que pour
moi ils ont aussi alors comme tous mais
ils ont leur vie devant eux
l'opportunité la créativité possible
mais que quoi qu'il arrive si ces jeunes
générations et vont l'être ou le seront
peut-être dans des situation économique
compliquée s'ils ont la chance d'avoir
des parents qui peuvent les aider
économiquement ce seront les boumeurs
ils seront là donc de trouver tous
spasmes en fait d'une manière ou d'une
autre les boumeurs paye et les boumeurs
soutiennent et donc de fait on est dans
une coopération et d'une entraide que ça
soit par des questions politiques
n'oublions pas qu'emmanuel mac pointe à
quadra et que de toute façon des
décisions présidentielles viennent non
pas d'un sexagénaire ou d'un baby boomer
mais n'a cadré génère mais que deux
fêtes sont nés il ya des décisions
politiques qui sont prises et qui ne
sont pas le fait d'individus mais que
deux fêtes derrière les individus à leur
échelle vont aussi accompagné comme ils
le pourront
leurs familles et et cette strate et cet
entourage familial et donc je pense que
c'est des éléments qu'il ne faut pas
qu'on m'oublie et et je reviens aussi
sur cette perspective de long terme
on a ici on est beaucoup dans l'instant
je comprends qu'on ait beaucoup de mal à
se projeter dans un monde incertain mais
que malgré tout comment on arrive aussi
à créer de l'espoir ça veut dire aussi
créé des opportunités qu'on n'a
peut-être pas encore en tête aujourd'hui
mais qui se font aussi des nouveaux
modèles pour demain emmanuel blésser ce
dernier mot non non je suis d'accord
mais simplement je pense que cette crise
du coc vide a misé sur le sur le
la place publique cette question de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle il
faudrait ouvrir le débat plus largement
sur d'autres questions
par exemple la question des retraites on
va vers un vieillissement de la
population une inversion de la pyramide
des âges
voilà il ya un système de retraite qui
devra être payée par les générations
futures comment on fait pour le financer
sachant qu'on aura 1.5 cotisant pour un
retraité en 2030
comment on fait pour le financer c'est
une question notre question parlant de
celle du patrimoine la transmission du
patrimoine
on a une génération qui s'est fortement
enrichi dans les années 1990 et 2000
parce que le patrimoine appris appris
appris beaucoup de appris beaucoup de
valeur donc il ya cette question de la
transmission du patrimoine ça sent qu
sachant qu'il se fait beaucoup plus tard
dans la vie donc à une égalité
générationnelle sur ce plan là il ne
s'agit pas encore une fois d'opposer
mais simplement de voir que la
solidarité intergénérationnelle doit
aller dans les deux sens
on l'a fait ça doit aller également dans
l'autre sens et c'est un débat qu'on
doit ouvrir pour l'avenir ensuite je
vais dans le sens de mélissa petit je
pense que ce qui compte c'est ce qu'on
fait pour l'avenir une période de crise
le l'étymologie nous le rappelle crise
ça vient de crise hisser la décision
donc c'est le moment où on décide donc
prendre des choix pourront prendre des
décisions pour l'avenir
donc il ya un monde à réinventer je
crois que la jeunesse de ce point de vue
là est une jeunesse très engagé c'est
une jeunesse qui qui l'a démontré sur la
question climatique notamment
donc il faut être optimiste sur l'avenir
et ça se fera évidemment en étant unis
et pas en étant opposés les uns aux
autres michel billé deux mots d'une part
le patrimoine
oui il ya des différences il ya sur nos
fins c'est quand même les jeunes
générations qui ont requis en hériteront
un peu plus tôt un peu plus tard mais de
fait elle en hériteront et je m'en
réjouis
et puis je voudrais ajouter du point de
vue du lien entre les générations
tu rajoutes et ceci c'est que l'argent
des vieux l'argent pour les vieux c'est
l'emploi des jeunes
et là nous avons un lien structurel qui
dont il faut prendre soin sans quoi
effectivement on irait vers une
catastrophe de de délier
non des générations la solidarité c'est
là qu'est ce qu'elle va se structurer se
construire se consolider l'emploi
l'argent des vieux l'argent pour les
vieux c'est l'emploi des jeunes et c'est
à regarder comme un investissement et
non pas comme une dépense andré comte
sponville dernier mot dernier mot mois
pour tout vous dire je m'inquiète
davantage des problèmes écologiques et
spécialement du réchauffement climatique
que de l'aco vide
or on a mis 100 milliards sur la table
pour compenser les effets du confinement
qu'on n'a pas mis sur la table pour
essayer de sauver comme on dit la
planète
et là encore qui va en suivirent le coup
dur et sur nos thématiques
ce sont nos enfants là encore ça me
donne envie de pleurer je vis un mot
mais vous pouvez en faire un peu plus
quand même il nous reste une minute
trente end que qui veut qu'ils veulent à
leur batteur main terminant sur une
terminant sur une note plus positive
l'important c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec moi je crois qu'il est temps
d'agir lors de ce point de vue il me
semble je suis pas économiste que les
mesures gouvernementales pour essayer de
sortir de cette crise économique vont
dans le bon sens sont sont très
importantes
je rêve je souhaite je veux qu'on se
donne des moyens comparables pour
combattre les catastrophes écologiques
et climatiques qui s'annoncent plutôt
que d'espérer et de crânes ce qui ne
dépend pas de nous commençons à faire ce
qu'ils ont dépensé la vieille leçon de
sagesse des stoïciens qu'on retrouve
chez montaigne et qui est toujours
d'actualité
mélissa petit à dernier mot vous avez
envie de d'ajouter quelque chose oui en
effet et bien il ya un potentiel aussi
d'emplois dans la silver economy auprès
des deux professionnels de soins de
santé d'accompagnement de la perte
d'autonomie
le rapport à une connerie note qu' entre
2020 et 2024 c'est à peu près 93 mille
postes qui doivent être créés dans ce
secteur là donc 2 p d'une certaine
manière on peut aussi créer des liens
économiques de cette dans cette façon là
je vous remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
à